Okay,
so
now Jacob,
we get the second part of Jacob's story.
He goes to meet his uncle Laban and
he meets Rachel there again by a well,
he falls in love button,
goes to live with Lebanon.
There are two daughters there,
Leah,
as well as Rachel.
Leah is not a particularly
attractive person.
It isn't exactly clear why,
but the story makes it quite clear.
She's definitely the least desirable of
the two daughters and the story makes
reference to her eyes and it isn't clear
if there's something wrong with her
physiologically or if there's
something wrong with her attitude.
It's not obvious,
but it doesn't really matter.
The point is she's the older daughter
but she's the less desirable one.
Jacob stays a month,
which is the limit of
hospitality in in that time,
if you stayed for a month,
you were welcomed but you
had to work for your keep.
I think after about three days,
something like that,
which seems rather reasonable and so
he stays a month and then he has a chat
with Labon and he says he's.
He's fallen in love with Rachel
by this time and he says,
I'll stay with you and
work for seven years,
and then all we had
Rachel and the band says,
that's fine deal,
and then the seven years passes
and there's a wedding ceremony.
It's quite a long thing
and the bride is veiled and
the bride goes into the tent with,
with Jacob and if I remember
the story correctly,
I haven't looked at it for a month or so.
Rachel is outside the tent speaking,
but Leah is inside the tent and so Jacob
thinks he's getting married to Rachel,
but he's actually getting
married to Leah and this is.
It's an inversion a because he's in
the dark like Isaac was when he fooled
Isaac.
So now it's Jacobs turned to be in the
dark and he gets betrayed by his uncle
and his bride to be Rachel and her sister
in a manner that's broadly parallel to
the trip that he pulled on Esau.
And so there is a Karma
notion there which I,
which I like,
you know,
I mean,
you might think of Karma as a
superstitious idea,
but.
And there are ways of interpreting
it that might make it the case,
but I don't think that's what it is.
It's that no bad deed goes
unpunished at something like that.
It's,
you know,
maybe you've done something bad to
someone and therefore there's part of you
that feels quite guilty
about that hopefully.
And that part is looking for
punishment to set the stage.
Right?
And you might think,
well no,
but things are,
yes,
unless you're a psychopath,
that's how things work.
If you're interested
in that kind of thing,
you should read Dostoyevsky's crime and
punishment because it's the definitive
study of that sort of phenomena.
Right?
Because in that book,
the main protagonists risk,
all Nicole gets away with murder,
like he does it successfully.
No one suspects him.
And he drives himself so crazy with guilt
that he basically falls into the hands
of the police.
He drives himself into the hands of the
police because he can't tolerate what he
did.
It's very,
it's amazing.
It's an amazing book.
But anyways,
the point is here,
Jacob falls prey to the same
sort of crookedness that
he used to ratchet himself
up the ladder and that happens far
more often in life than people think.
And it's really not like he can complain
about it right now if he has any sense.
It's like he does.
He brings Leah out to
see Labon and he says,
what's,
what's with this sister?
You know?
And Lebaron basically says to him
in our culture,
it's the custom to marry
the eldest daughter first,
which is exactly right.
And he said,
well,
it would bring,
you know,
he's rationalizing obviously because
he's just screwed over Jacob in a major
way,
but it's a little late to take it back.
The marriage has been consummated and
the ceremony has been complete and all
hell would break out if there was any
attempt to sever the relationship.
So that's how it is.
So Leah's married and
Jacob has the wrong wife.
So then,
so this is Jacob there you see on the
left he's got the little flowery hat and
he's pointing to Leah
and he's saying like,
what?
What's up here?
And loved the band,
you know,
La Banda is coupled goat and he's
not really all that sad about it.
In fact,
you can imagine that he's going to go in,
so okay.
Then he asked to work another seven years
and he gains Rachel.
But because God is a tricky character,
there was another twist in this story.
Rachel turns out not to be very good
at having children or Rachel and Jacob
turned out not to be very
good in having children,
but Leah,
she's really good at having kids,
so she provides Jacob with Reuben,
simeon,
Levi,
believe and Judah.
And the names of those meanings
of those names are there.
Reuben means see a son.
Simeon means hearing the.
I think that was the Lord heard my prayer.
I think that's what that was.
Levi means joined.
Judah means praise too.
Yeah,
well,
and it's Judah from WHO's
tried Christ arises.
Judah is essentially promoted
to the status of first born.
Later in the story.
This is important because Ruben,
simeon and Levy all do something
reprehensible and so Judah gets,
gets promoted to firstborn,
and that's partly why in the logic of
the narrative that it's from the tribe of
Judah that Christ arises,
so,
so now while this is going on,
Rachel is like suicidal,
desperate for children's.
She's jealous of her older sister who's
rather ill favored as we pointed out,
but who seems to be damn good at producing
sons and she's really not happy with
Jacob,
and so she chose him out and
Jacob basically says like,
what do you want me to do about it?
I'm not God,
which is a reasonable
response I would say,
and so in her desperation
she gives Jacob Bella,
who's her maid servant.
We've seen that sort of
thing happened before and
to bill up produces two children.
Dan and NAF telly.
I'm the reason I'm detailing
out all these sons.
It's important because Jacob is the
founder of Israel and his sons are the
founder of the 12 tribes,
so it's a pivotal moment in the story,
right?
It's because he's the.
He's the fundamental patriarch of,
of those who wrestle with
God because as we'll see,
that's what the name Israel means.
He gets the name Israel.
You'll see why in a while,
but,
but it's in the,
you need to know these genealogies in
this situation because they play an
important role in everything
that happens afterwards.
So
Naftali is the second
and her name or his name
means with great wrestling's.
I've wrestled with my sister,
right,
contended with her and have prevailed.
So that gives you some indication
of the tension in the household.
Now Leah is now past bearing children.
She gives Jake,
Jacob,
her maid servant Zilpah to
keep up with her sister,
I guess.
And uh,
now Zilpah bears to children for Jacob.
So he's piling up the kids
left right and center here.
I'm,
one of them is named Gad,
good fortune.
And the other is named Asher.
Happy or blessed.
So there's more rivalry
going on between the sisters.
This is quite an interesting little story.
So Ruben,
who's Leah's daughter,
goes out and looks for mandrakes.
Now mandrakes have aphrodisiac property.
So that's a little odd to begin with,
but it doesn't matter.
That's what happens.
And uh,
Rachel is,
Rachel wants the mandrakes because
she's still interested in having some
children and so she bargains with
Leah to give her a night with Jacob in
exchange for the mandrakes and a more
sons emerge as a consequence of that.
So,
and Rachel find the gifts,
birth Joseph and Joseph plays a key
role in the last story in Genesis,
which I hope we'll get
to in the next lecture.
And then we can close off genesis.
That's the plan.
Anyways.
So now Jacob isn't really very happy
about the whole arrangement because he,
he's been there 14 years
and he's got two wives.
It's not too bad,
but he,
you know,
he got the bargain wasn't exactly clean.
He doesn't really trust law bannon and
there's no reason for him to do so.
Lebanon was poor before Jacob came.
Jacob turns out to be a very
useful person to have around.
And so he tells labounty he wants to
leave and go back to his home country and
that he'll take the
speckled and spotted cattle,
the brown sheep.
And the spotted and speckled
goats from the flock,
and they're in the minority.
So that's the idea.
And so ban or lab and takes all
those animals out of his flock.
So the.
There was an idea that the speckled goats
and the brown sheep would breed true.
So if you have two male goat and a
female goat and they're both speckled,
they'll have speckled kits.
That's the theory.
And the same with brown sheep.
And so what [inaudible] does is he takes
all the speckled animals out of the
flocks,
gives them to his son,
and they go three days away with them
so that Jacob is left with the flock.
But with no,
with none of these animals.
Now the idea was that
all the one newborns,
we're going to be his.
And so what Liban is basically done is
set it up so that in principle I'm Jacob
is going to get nothing for his work.
So that's another time when
Jacob experiences betrayal.
You know,
it's almost as if God isn't done with
reminding him of the magnitude of what he
did in the past.
That that's the moral of the story.
In some sense,
now there's a weird little
twist in the story here.
So what Jacob does is some sympathetic
magic and so when the animals are
rotting,
he puts speckled objects in front of them,
speckled branches and so forth,
I guess to remind them about what
they're supposed to be producing,
something like that.
And it works.
And so all these animals
that laband left are,
are,
uh,
producing spotted animals like mad.
And so that's,
I guess God's changed his mind and
let Jacob off the hook slightly here.
So Sooni was very wealthy,
much cattle maid servants,
men servants,
Campbell's analysis,
laband son,
sons become jealous.
And lavonne is outraged.
Well,
you know,
obviously there's some competition
there between Jacob and his sons,
which is hardly surprising.
And the band played this trick to strip
Jacob of all his property and instead he
got far more than he was
going to get to begin with.
So you can imagine that
spirit a bit annoying.
So Jacob,
thanks.
He better get out of there.
So we tell Rachel and
Leah and said unto them,
I see your father's countenance
that it's not toward me as before.
But the god of my father has
been with me and you know,
with all my power,
I've served your father and your father
is deceived me and changed my wages 10
times,
but God so far has suffered
him not to hurt me if he said,
thus the speckled shall be thy wages,
then all the cattle bore speckled,
and if he said,
thus the ring straight shall be thy
higher than all the cattle board ring
strict.
Thus God has taken away the cattle of
your father and given them to me and they
decided to sneak away and they're
unhappy with the inheritance.
That lack of inheritance from Lebanon.
So as they sneak away,
Rachel steals the idols that her father
has in his house and it's not exactly
obvious why.
There's a lot of contention
about why she's doing that.
Some of them is to punish him,
to bring with her the
images of her ancestors.
You know,
maybe she's loaned some
moving away from home,
just out of spite to show them that
the idols were actually powerless for
protection,
to stop her father from dividing
the root of their escape.
That last one is the strangest one because
the idea would be that the ban would
have used some sort of ritual with the
idols that would help them infer their
escape route and then could chase them.
So anyways,
that's the range of
speculation about that.
I think it sounds to me mostly like a
little act of revenge maybe with a bit of
loneliness mixed in laband pursues them,
but God comes into dream to tell
him to leave Jacob unharmed.
Lavonne catches up with them in
reproaches Jacob saying that he would have
thrown a great party if he would have
known that they were going to leave,
you know,
he didn't want them to
sneak away in the night.
And you can't tell from the
story whether that's true or not.
And you know,
these people were pretty rough
and impulsive I would say.
And maybe there is a 50 percent chance
of a slaughter and a 50 percent chance of
a party.
Who knows?
I've been to parties like that actually.
So
laband complains that his gods are gone
and Jacob says that whoever has them,
he will have them killed.
And Rachel,
who's really quite a sneaky character,
all things consider basically claims
that she's having her period and she's
sitting on the carpet with all the
idols underneath and she can't move.
And so they search everywhere
and can't find them.
And she's like laughing away behind her
hand about that sneaky little maneuver.
But she,
she doesn't die.
So that's probably a good thing.
So the laband,
she checks everything out,
checks the camp out and
he can't find anything.
So they reconcile.
And so that's the first
reconciliation that Jacob in.
It's sort of like
the,
what would you say the
Karmic debt has been paid.
That's one way of thinking about it.
That's so he got punished
for his wrongdoing.
He's learned his lesson perhaps.
And it's,
it's,
that's good enough.
As far as he's concerned,
he got away good enough
and they make peace.
So
then the next thing that happens as
they're traveling is that Jacob was left
alone and there wrestled a man,
man,
Angel.
God,
it's not clear.
We'll go with angel with him until
the breaking of the day or God.
And when he saw that he
prevailed not against him,
he touched the hollow of his thigh and
the hollow of Jacob's thigh was out of
joint as he wrestled with him and he said,
let me go for the day breaks.
And Jacob said,
I will not let you go unless you bless me.
And the Angel said unto him,
what is the name?
And Jacob said,
Jacob.
And the Angel said,
thy name shall no more be called Jacob.
So the supplanter right,
the overthrow her with that
kind of intonation of or
implication of crookedness
but Israel,
which means he who wrestles or strive
successfully with God for as a prince,
hast thou power with God and
with men and has prevailed.
That's quite a story.
Like it's.
I don't,
I don't know exactly what to make of it.
There's obviously a
symbolic level of meaning,
which is that that is what human
beings do in some senses they,
they wrestle.
I would say they wrestle with the divine
even with the concept of the divine for
that matter.
And,
but the question is,
do they prevail?
Like it's kind of odd thing that Jacob
actually seems to win this battle,
right?
Or at least he wins it enough so that
whoever he's wrestling this divine figure
that he's wrestling is willing
to bestow a blessing on him.
I guess maybe that's a
testament to his courage.
It's something like that.
Maybe it's an indication that he has
paid for his sin sufficiently so that he
sort of back on the moral high ground.
But,
but I think it's really telling that the
transformation of the name from Jacob
Israel and what Israel means is he who
wrestles with God or who struggles with
God and perhaps successfully,
but it's also so interesting that
he actually emerges victorious.
You know,
you wouldn't necessarily think
that that would be a possibility,
especially given you know,
God's rather hot headed
nature in the Old Testament.
You don't want to mess with him too much,
but,
but Jacob does it successfully.
But even more importantly is the idea
that whatever Israel constitutes,
which would be the say,
the land that Jacob phones is actually
composed of those who wrestle with God.
I think that's an amazing idea because
it also seems to me to shed some light on
perhaps what was meant
by belief in those days.
You know,
like I've often thought of rep
of marriage as a wrestling match,
right?
If you're lucky,
the person that you marry,
someone you contend with,
it's not exactly.
I don't think it's exactly.
It's not tranquil.
Precisely.
You know,
you might have noticed
that some of you and,
but,
but the thing is if you have
something to contend against,
then that strengthens you and that's
actually better than having nothing to
contend against.
And so Jacob is the person who's also
strengthened by the necessity of this
contending and that seems to be the proper
relationship with God or the angel is
that contending the battling,
right?
Rather than some sort of kind of loose,
weak statement of belief.
I mean,
I'm not trying to denigrate
that to any great degree.
It just doesn't seem like the
right motive conceptualization,
right?
Because human beings aren't,
aren't like that were were contentious
creatures and that's actually seems to be
something that meets with
God's favor in this situation.
So especially given that that's actually
what he names the while the whole
kingdom of the chosen people is the idea
is that that's composed of those who
contend with God.
So that's,
that's a hell of an idea
that that's for sure.
And Jacob asked
him and said,
tell me I pray thee thy name.
And he said,
wherefore dos ask after by name.
So there's no that's not happening.
And he blessed him there.
And Jacob called the place
of the name of that place.
Penile for I or Peniel for I have seen
God face to face in my life is preserved.
And he passed over penile.
The Sun rose upon him and
he halted upon his thigh.
Now Jacob does walk
away injured from this,
right?
So he has a permanent limp after that.
And so that's also an indication of just
how dangerous that contention actually
is.
Like he gets blast,
he wins,
but he doesn't get away Scot free.